Transcriptor: Emma Gon
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Hoy he venido a hablar
de los animales
que están más explotados
y más infravalorados
de nuestro planeta.
Estos animales de los
que hoy quiero hablar,
son criaturas inteligentes,
sociales, sensibles
y tienen las increíbles capacidades,
por ejemplo, de usar herramientas,
colaboran entre ellos y tienen memoria;
algunos incluso son capaces
de reconocerse en un espejo.
Imagino que con esta descripción
que os estoy dando,
la mayoría pensaréis, bueno,
que hoy he venido a hablar
de los grandes simios, de los elefantes,
de los delfines, pues no.
Hoy he venido a hablar de los peces.
Y de hecho, hace poco tiempo
que trabajo sobre peces
desde hace poco, pero durante 10 años,
me dedicaba a
la investigación científica
en el campo de la microbiología marina,
porque siempre me ha fascinado
la inmensidad de los océanos
y sus desconocidos habitantes.
No sé si lo sabéis,
pero los océanos son el ecosistema
más grande de la Tierra,
ocupan el 70 % de la capa terrestre
y como dato curioso, os diré
que el 50 % del oxígeno que respiramos
proviene de los océanos.
Concretamente de los microorganismos
que hacen la fotosíntesis.
Aquí os he puesto un par de fotos
para que os hagáis una idea de cómo son.
Pero a pesar de
la importancia de los océanos,
conocemos aún muy poco
de cómo funcionan
y de sus desconocidos habitantes.
Para que os hagáis una idea,
se dice que conocemos mejor
la superficie de la luna
que el fondo de nuestros océanos.
Por eso yo me dediqué
durante tanto tiempo
al estudio de
los microorganismos del mar.
Pero desde hace poco,
me dedico junto a
varios compañeros de la ONG,
Compassion in World Farming,
que es una ONG que se dedica
a la protección de los animales
y que en español quiere decir,
Compasión en el Mundo de
la Ganadería Industrial,
nos dedicamos al estudio
y a la protección
de los otros grandes desconocidos
organismos acuáticos,
que son los peces.
Yo decidí hacer este cambio
en mi carrera profesional
y a la vez, en mi vida, porque
siempre he sido una gran apasionada
y una gran admiradora de
los animales y del mundo animal.
Y me preocupaba, pero sobre todo,
me indignaba muchísimo
cómo tratamos hoy en día, mejor dicho,
cómo maltratamos
hoy en día a los animales.
Los peces son los animales
que menos valoramos del planeta.
Y, además, no han generado
mucho interés
ni mucha curiosidad
por el público en general.
Hoy os quiero mostrar
que son animales igual de curiosos,
de interesantes,
de inteligentes como el resto
y espero con ello despertar
vuestra admiración, vuestra curiosidad,
pero, sobre todo,
vuestro respeto hacia ellos.
Porque creo que se merecen
la misma consideración
y la misma protección
por parte de nosotros.
Los peces son seres que sienten
y perciben su alrededor,
se adaptan a su entorno,
y tienen un amplio mundo sensorial.
No sé si os lo habéis planteado nunca
pero los peces ven debajo del agua
y ven tan nítidamente
como nosotros vemos en el aire
y ven a color.
Incluso ven más colores que nosotros.
Los peces también
oyen debajo del agua,
aunque no tengan orejas;
pero si no tiene orejas,
es porque no las necesitan,
porque el sonido
se transmite mucho mejor
en el agua que en el aire.
Los peces también tienen
el sentido del gusto
y lo sabemos porque tienen
papilas gustativas como nosotros
en la lengua, pero también las tienen
en el labio y en el hocico.
Los peces también tienen
sentido del olfato,
un fino sentido del olfato,
que es muy útil para los peces
que son migratorios para orientarse.
Además de estos sentidos,
los peces tienen otro sentidos
que nosotros no poseemos.
Por ejemplo, los tiburones,
las mantas y las rayas tienen
el sentido de la electro recepción,
es decir que pueden generar
y percibir la electricidad.
Otros peces tienen sensores
que les permiten detectar
los cambios de presión del agua
y los cambios de vibración del agua.
Eso les permite también orientarse,
evitar colisiones y también pueden
detectar, gracias a estos sensores,
los peces que nadan a su alrededor.
No solo detectan el pez, sino también
el tamaño y a la velocidad que va.
Curiosamente otros peces
también tienen unas células
que les sirven como brújulas;
estas células detectan
los campos magnéticos de la Tierra
que entonces permite a
los peces migratorios, orientarse.
Aparte de todo
este gran mundo sensorial
que tienen los peces,
también tienen comportamientos
muy inteligentes y muy complejos.
Sabemos que los peces, muchos de ellos,
son sociales, viven en grupos
y no son aleatorios.
Tienen jerarquías y
se reconocen entre ellos.
Y como decía, no son grupos aleatorios,
se coordinan para nadar juntos.
Los peces también juegan,
los peces hacen
rituales de apareamiento
entre machos y hembras,
y los peces tiene buena memoria.
La típica frase que decimos
para referirnos a alguien
que tiene mala memoria, decimos,
"Tienes memoria de pez".
Pues eso es un mito y
es completamente erróneo,
los peces tienen muy buena memoria.
De hecho, los peces
son capaces de aprender
como este pez arquero que vemos aquí
que ha sido entrenado para distinguir
entre diferentes caras humanas
y lo adiestran igual que adiestraríamos
nosotros a nuestro perro;
le dan premios de comida,
cuando acierta la cara
que tiene que reconocer,
recibe un premio de comida.
Los peces también cuidan de sus crías.
Aquí vemos una especie,
que es un cíclido,
que introducirá a todos sus crías
en el interior de su boca para
protegerlas de un posible depredador.
Esta madre es capaz de
estar dos meses sin comer
para proteger a sus crías.
Y los peces usan herramientas.
Aquí vemos otra especie de cíclido,
que está cogiendo una concha,
para intentar abrirla,
lo que usará es
el borde de una piedra
que la golpeará para poder
abrir la concha y comer su interior.
El comportamiento
de utilizar herramientas,
hasta hace poco, se creía
que era exclusivo de humanos.
porque es un comportamiento
muy complejo.
Pero recientemente hemos visto
que muchos grupos animales
lo pueden realizar,
y entre ellos, los peces.
Este pez sabe perfectamente
lo que está haciendo,
no es un comportamiento aleatorio.
Sabe por qué lo está haciendo
y con qué finalidad lo hace,
de hecho, repetirá
el comportamiento
hasta que sea capaz
de abrir la concha.
Los peces también
colaboran entre ellos,
como este mero y esta morena,
que colaboran para cazar.
El mero ha detectado
presas dentro de la roca,
en los agujeros de la roca,
y avisa a la morena,
que gracias a su forma alargada,
podrá introducirse
dentro de los huecos
y hacer salir a las presas.
Así los dos serán capaces,
bueno intentarán,
cazar las presas.
Este comportamiento de
colaboración entre especies
es muy raro, en el mundo animal;
la capacidad de comunicarse
entre dos especies diferentes.
Pero en cambio,
sí que sucede en los peces.
El problema de los peces
es que no los vemos
ni los imaginamos
como os los estoy describiendo.
Si, por ejemplo,
les nombro la palabra atún,
seguramente a la mayoría,
se os vendrá a la cabeza,
la lata de atún.
Pero a pocas personas,
se les viene a la cabeza,
el animal que es el atún;
y el atún es un animal
que puede llegar
a medir tres metros,
pesar 700 kilos
y es uno de los animales acuáticos
más rápidos que existen,
puede llegar a alcanzar los 80 km/h,
incluso pueden sumergirse
a mil metros de profundidad.
El atún es uno de los grandes
depredadores de nuestros océanos.
En cambio,
cuando pensamos en el atún,
pensamos en la latita de atún.
Lo mismo sucede, si yo por ejemplo,
os digo la palabra salmón.
A la mayoría
se os viene a la cabeza,
el filete de salmón,
el sushi de salmón;
pero pocos pensamos en
los animales que son los salmones.
Y el salmón es un animal
muy interesante y muy curioso.
Son animales migratorios,
que llegan a nadar miles de kilómetros
a lo largo de su vida
para retornar al río
donde nacieron y desovar,
es decir, poner los huevos.
Y si pueden hacer eso,
es gracias a su fino olfato,
que les permite reconocer
el camino a casa.
La gran pregunta
la he querido dejar para el final.
Para mí la pregunta más importante,
y que quiero que
reflexionéis sobre ella hoy, es:
¿son capaces
los peces de sentir dolor?
Y la respuesta es sí,
los peces son capaces
de sentir dolor.
De hecho, los peces
tienen los mismos sensores
del dolor que tenemos nosotros
y se ha comprobado científicamente
que reaccionan al dolor
como reaccionamos nosotros;
que incluso muestran alivio
si les suministramos digamos morfina.
Por lo tanto, cuando pescamos
y utilizamos ganchos para pescar,
este pez está sintiendo dolor.
Es posible que nosotros
no percibamos ese dolor
porque el pez no lo expresa
igual que otros animales,
o el pez no puede chillar.
Pero que nosotros
no podamos identificar ese dolor,
no significa que no exista.
Además, los peces
aparte de sentir dolor,
los peces se estresan,
cuando, por ejemplo,
los sacamos del agua
o los manipulamos.
Muchas de las prácticas
habituales de las piscifactorías
incluyen procedimientos que estresan
muchísimo a los animales.
En las granjas de peces,
las densidades suelen ser muy altas
y esto estresa a los animales
porque son incapaces de reproducir
su comportamiento natural.
Además, en las granjas de peces
manipulamos a los animales,
por ejemplo,
para la extracción de huevos.
Y a la hora del sacrificio, capturamos
a los animales con estas redes,
los sacamos fuera del agua
y el método más habitual
de sacrificio de los peces
es introducirlos en estos tanques
con agua e hielo directamente
sin anestesia.
La mayoría de estos animales
morirá por asfixia
y esto será una muerte
lenta y dolorosa.
Los peces fuera del agua
sienten lo mismo
que nosotros dentro del agua,
se asfixian, se ahogan.
Pero los peces pueden
llegar a tardar en asfixiarse,
mucho más tiempo que nosotros,
pueden ser minutos, pero incluso horas.
Aquí vemos cómo los peces,
si llegan a ser empaquetados,
que siguen vivos.
Este video que os puedo mostrar
es gracias a una de las investigaciones
que hicimos de nuestra ONG.
Este pez lleva aquí una hora y media
y sigue vivo, empaquetado y vivo.
Yo creo que esta es una muerte cruel
y que no deberíamos permitir
que esto sucediera.
Creo también que los peces se merecen
una muerte digna;
y con una muerte digna
me refiero a una muerte sin dolor,
sin estrés y sin sufrimiento.
Esto es lo que sucede
en algunas de las granjas de peces,
pero si hablamos de
los parques industriales de pesca,
la situación no es mucho mejor.
Los barcos de pesca están dotados
de estas redes gigantes,
que en un solo día
con una sola red y un solo barco,
llegan a pescar millones de animales.
Después del estrés de
ser capturados en el agua
y ser subidos a bordo,
la mayoría de estos animales,
siguen vivos.
Estos animales morirán por asfixia,
algunos por aplastamiento,
a otros se les revientan los órganos
por los cambios de presión
del agua al subirlos a bordo.
Cuando los subimos a bordo,
siguen vivos, muchos de ellos.
Seguimos trabajando
y manipulando las redes
cuando los animales siguen vivos.
Aquí vemos tres personas
que están andando encima de la red,
cuando el animal sigue vivo.
Si esta red estuviera
llena de cachorritos
o gatitos, estaríamos escandalizados.
Pero como son peces, nos da igual.
Nos parece de lo más normal.
El número de peces
que matamos anualmente
es desorbitado.
Para que os hagáis una idea,
matamos 4000 millones de mamíferos
para el consumo humano anualmente.
Si hablamos de aves,
sacrificamos 70 000 millones
y aquí incluyo, pollos, patos y pavos.
Pero si hablamos de peces,
tengo que cambiar la escala,
porque el número es muchísimo mayor.
Estamos hablando de
30 000 billones de animales
que sacrificamos anualmente.
Yo no sé vosotros, pero para mí,
para hacerme una idea
de qué representa este número
es casi imposible.
Os voy a hacer una comparación.
Este número equivale a más
de 140 veces la población mundial,
es decir que al año matamos
en números de peces
más de 140 veces la población mundial.
Esto es una masacre.
Yo espero que con la charla
que os he hecho hoy,
haberos convencido de
que los peces son seres que sienten
y que ahora los veáis
como los animales inteligentes,
complejos e interesantes que son.
Con ello me gustaría convenceros
de que merecen el mismo respeto
y la misma consideración que el resto.
Y cuando hablo también de protegerlos
no me refiero de protegernos
únicamente a nivel poblacional.
Es decir, de que nos preocupemos
de que el día de mañana sigamos
teniendo poblaciones de peces
para seguir pescando
y para seguir consumiendo,
sino que a mí me gustaría
que nos preocupáramos
de los peces también
a nivel individual;
porque yo creo que cada vida cuenta
y que nos tendríamos que preocupar
de su bienestar y de su sufrimiento.
Creo que ellos merecen
una vida y una muerte dignas.
Por lo tanto hoy, os invito
a redescubrir los peces.
(Aplausos)